it's always young people that have the
that that their frontal well
a they they they they have all of this
energy
all of this passion and they want to
change the world right i mean you you
talk about young people
and always talking about they they want
cultural change they want a revolution
and they want to be part of something
bigger than themselves
a lot of a lot of the the older folks
i'm 50 now
uh we we have gray hair which is a sign
of wisdom we've been around a while to
see
that all this history stuff is actually
important
and so uh when you're young you need a
vision
and and so i think that if we give the
vision
as older wiser people who understand
that ideas have consequences
that history can teach us uh about where
we're headed in the future
that if they get on board with with that
and they're inspired
if if uh if if they catch the vision
that's rooted in the right stuff i think
that
that not only i don't think that they
who are going to make the difference
i'm banking on the power of god
working in their hearts and through
their minds uh to make better decisions
than we've made in this generation
that's where my hope is
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
an 80 sitcom legend
a touring speaker bringing the gospel
across america
and the host of the campfire revival on
facebook and instagram
kirk cameron welcome to the reuben
report hey
dave it's so good to be talking with you
i hope you don't mind me bringing you
into my backyard like this i just
thought it might be a little different
for your
for your program and the viewers kirk i
believe this is the first time and i
don't know man
how many hundreds or thousands of shows
that i've done that someone has done it
outdoors
with a fire and an american flag i've
never been prouder
you know it's gotta i just feel like we
got to go grassroots we got to get real
we got and it's just this is this is as
real as it gets for me i got my tomato
garden off to the left
i got a fire here s'mores in a couple of
hours and you know we're gonna play like
born in the usa
uh with the flag waving in the breeze
here pretty soon are you allowed to have
an american flag just waving in the
breeze in crazy california i don't wanna
i don't wanna out you my friend but you
are
in crazy california not too far from me
well i spend enough time in florida and
texas and
and tennessee to kind of balance it out
so uh
uh i love it out here though you know
it's a it's it's a beautiful state
and uh it's my hope and my prayer
that good people across this state will
begin to reclaim the values
uh that that that we want and we want to
see them represented in this state and
not abandon it
all right well we're going to get to
some of those values we're going to get
to that flag behind you we're going to
get to the campfire and all that but i
got to start
at the beginning and the beginning for
us
is the 80s you were on growing pains it
was like the number one show for a
couple years at least how many seasons
was it on total
like i believe or seven seasons yeah six
or seven seasons definitely number one
at some point
abc i remember eight o'clock kirk
cameron growing
you watching as a little kid i mean be
honest yeah did you
watch i was not only watching as a
little kid but but i did my research so
the show came out in 85 i was about
eight nine years old
and there was a belief in my high school
i grew up in syocid in long island that
we knew that
that growing pains took place in long
island there was a rumor it took place
in syosset
but we discussed this once when i met
you off camera
you actually told me it took place one
town over is that correct
it took place in huntington long island
one town
one town over on a street called robin
hood lane i don't know if that's a real
street
we had a robin's lane we had a robin's
lane where i grew up
okay well that was in syocid maybe in
huntington it was robin hood lane i
don't know
well anyway you were on a show that that
to me like
sort of just captured what my childhood
was like and you know you're a couple
years older than me but we were
basically the same age
my demeanor was very much the demeanor
of mike seaver on that show kind of
happy go lucky
sort of popular whatever that that whole
thing
um you were a star at a pretty young age
what was that like
well you know when i look back i have
kids now so i have six children and i
look back and i think man i would never
have
i would never want them to be in the
environment that i was in just because
it is uh it's so precarious it's so
dangerous i mean how many child
tv stars do you see that grow up and
they they turn out with their head on
their shoulders
uh and you know where they're not in
jail or they're not
you know just jumping off some some
crazy uh
cliff in in in some way and i think wow
for me it was my only normal i can't
compare it to a different childhood
uh and fortunately i had good people
around me um but yeah it was it was very
strange at 14 years old people asking me
for my autograph i thought
are you kidding this is some kind of a
joke but then it went on and on
and uh you know i i it was a crazy
adventure
but one that was um beautiful i'm
thankful i
met my wife i got to work on projects
that i'm passionate about all because
of growing pains and uh i just want to
be a good steward of these opportunities
in the platform
now uh rather than just taking advantage
and um you know looking out for me so
you met your wife chelsea 29 years ago
on the set
is that right on the set we're gonna
we're gonna celebrate 30 years this year
so i married mike seaver's girlfriend so
you may remember that beautiful bro
who showed up on the set because i sure
do and uh
interestingly i actually met her first
on my sister candace cameron's show
full house and uh a year later she
showed up as mike seaver's girlfriend
and then i stole her away from mike
siever
behind the scenes and i married her and
uh we're gonna be celebrating 30 years
this year that's hilarious you stole her
from mike seaver
you also work that's very deep that's
very deep
he he didn't deserve her not not at all
no no
yeah he he he uh he always saw too many
fish in the sea he was playing the field
i was like no
i'm i'm a one-woman guy so i i moved in
and um i i managed to make her laugh the
first time i kissed her on screen
and uh that was way ahead of our our our
real life relationship
in the in the show i actually had to
kiss her mike siever had to kiss her
and i made her laugh i think that was
the charm that set the hook and uh
now she's mine and here we are and you
guys did all the the serious stuff you
know the 80s had their melancholy
episodes there was the episode where you
you and your friends went to that party
and a bunch of them did cocaine but you
but mike did not and you've grown up
yeah you've grown up to be a good family
man six freaking kids that's nuts
that well it is you know unless you're
the duggars uh then that's that's just
light work
but but uh but it's been you know it's
kind of like the brady bunch
uh i i i don't have alice the maid or
sam the butcher
but uh we got a house full of kids it's
been awesome they're grown now so my
kids are now 23 22 21
20 19 and 18. and so i've got proposals
and marriages i've got
college and graduations and so we're
just kind of
dealing with the gamut of it right now
and it's uh it's
it's always a growing experience not
just for them but for us as parents
are you saying there are growing pains
involved kirk i
i am i am but i wanted you to say it not
me
thank you so talk to me a little bit
about the show
ends and then eventually you kind of
reappeared and you started talking
more about faith and the things that
mattered to you and then
the media was kind of not that nice
about it right
or did that take a little while at first
it was good it was you know what it was
good fodder
for uh for the tabloid shows it was good
rating stuff but
in reality what what happened was uh i
was an atheist
i i was one of one of one of uh of many
people who just
you know never really thought about god
never thought about faith i had more
faith in myself
you know or or people that i looked up
to and then one day
uh a pretty young girl invited me to uh
meet
her family and they went to church and
so i i was an atheist and so i wasn't
interested in
in the church i was interested in the
girl but i figured if i was ever going
to see her again
i i couldn't tell them what i really
believed but that at the end of that day
i was really intrigued
and i was captured by the message that i
heard and i began investigating and
eventually came to the conclusion that
maybe
maybe this isn't all an accident and
maybe i don't know everything
and eventually became persuaded that the
message of the gospel
and the message in the bible was one
that i wanted to embrace with all of my
heart
and i began going that way and it it
really uh
changed my trajectory not only
personally but i wanted my
my my personal beliefs and convictions
which i felt were were right
to line up with the things i did
professionally because i knew it would
influence other people you know kind of
like what i think
you're doing a beautiful job of taking
the values that mean something to you
and helping to spread them because you
want to produce
uh you know human flourishing you don't
want to squash that with bad ideas but
up
uplift it and help it with good ideas
were you surprised when you started
talking about that and and doing some
other shows and doing some stuff on your
own and i assume you probably your
agents must have been like oh no he's
going in this road
you know he's going down this road this
ain't gonna fly yeah
yeah that that kind of stuff did start
to happen and um
you know really it was a i mean imagine
i'm 70 imagine
you dave you're 17 years old you're on a
tv show
i would rather be playing basketball
with my friends but i got i got a huge
responsibility and kind of like whatever
i do
affects all these other people and their
livelihood
and i'm feeling like hey i think some of
these jokes for this family show in the
80s
is is really kind of maybe sending kids
down the wrong road
and so i would i would request for a
line change
well that could be seen as flexing
celebrity muscle from a 17 year old kid
who
who thinks he's all that when really all
i wanted to do was was be able to go to
sleep at night with a clear conscience
and so uh people started to get upset
and
uh then all kinds of you know
entertainment crazy stories were coming
out you know kirk cameron born again
kirk cameron tanks the show uh he has
actress fired
when in when reality uh that wasn't it
at all
and um you know i i i look back on
growing pains and i see
there were ups and downs there were
there was challenges but ultimately
that's where i found out who my true
friends are and and that's where
where my where my faith in god was
actually strengthened
because it really caused me to examine
the things that i that i that i hold
dear and and make sure that they're that
that they're tested and that they're
true so as a guy that
grew up as a as a kid and as an atheist
i suppose
on television then you have your kind of
awakening does it surprise you that
that hollywood is kind of where it's at
at the moment which
i'm sure most of my viewers will agree
is not a great place
does it surprise me well you know
uh i i guess i don't know whether it
surprises me or not
um one of the things that i find
interesting is that when people
uh are afraid of public shame or
humiliation or condemnation
uh we don't like that right and so we
tend to like hide and we
we don't let people see who we are or
really what we believe and i i think
unfortunately people within the family
have faith
have uh have felt that way and sort of
kept that stuff under wraps
even though um the world is increasingly
religious
uh i i believe that we were actually
designed to know and to love uh
god and and so we wind up worshiping
something if it's not god
whether it's yourself or it's the
government or it's a group of people you
think are smarter
but ultimately uh fr from that that that
source will come
our laws and it will dictate our
morality and all that kind of thing
i hope that people of faith will begin
to
not divorce that faith from the arts and
entertainment
i hope that they'll take their faith in
their values and let it
permeate the things that will then shape
the culture
and i think when we see more and more
faith-based movies doing better and
better at the box office
you look at the chosen and you see how
well that's doing you look at the
quality of that you look at the passion
of the christ years ago and and even the
movie
that i just finished uh i think that
people are
are are beginning to say like wait a
minute there's not only a market for
this
but uh this is actually communicating
good messages that most of us i believe
in america
understand we're getting away from and
we want to get back to those things
so i'm hoping for a revival uh not just
you know in in the heart of people of
faith but in hollywood
and in government and in the marketplace
and everywhere else
are you hopeful just because of how
crazy the last year and a half was
i've sort of come around to that that i
think so many people
you know yeah people are depressed
they're angry they're confused all that
stuff but
it caused them to look at their live
their lives more seriously
so i'm hopeful for that yeah i think
you're right and i think that
dave at the end of the day um you know
if you and i jump off a building
um we we don't break the law of gravity
the law of gravity breaks
us there are things that are built into
the world that are non-negotiables and i
think that false systems will always end
up failing they may
flourish for a while but it's kind of
like kind of like that big tree that you
see in the background
sometimes you know these these oak trees
get so big and top heavy with all their
big
uh impressive branches but if the root
system underneath
is not as developed if it's not down
deep
all it takes is a strong wind and the
thing topples itself
because it's way too top-heavy and i
think our culture
is getting that way eventually it will
teeter and topple over because
our foundational roots of faith and
morality and virtue that our founders
said were absolutely essential for a
free society
have begun to rot and we've neglected
them so if we see rotten fruit
culturally i think
that the real answer is a systemic
answer
and we need to go down and we need to
begin to nourish the roots again
so you're sort of answering my next
question but how does the faith
part that was pretty good what you did
there how does the faith part get you to
that flag behind you and sort of
shape you know what you believe
politically yeah
well i've never i'm really not a
political guy i'm
a family guy i would say i'm a faith guy
um
but i have kids in the world and i and i
i think to myself what's the place going
to be like in 20 years
that's a that's a terrifying question
when i think about where we're headed
right now politically
economically morally spiritually um
that's why i'm glad for your program i'm
glad for
uh for for many others who are who are
communicating this message
and so what i did is as i said you know
what
um guys like george washington people
like uh
um abraham lincoln and and and the
pilgrims even
uh said that faith and morality are
absolute essential
for a free and just society and so i
began researching and educating myself
and i found that that the people who
built this country
did something that we're not doing
anymore and that is they're making these
these sacred promises with one another
to covenant together
it's not just a legal contract that we
can show to a judge later when somebody
uh screws up and
and and uh you know uh breaks the
contract
but it's it's this sense that till death
do us part
are we are going to have each other's
back and we're going to do the right
thing from the heart
and we're going to promise with god as
well that that if that if he would
protect us if he would guide us
that we we trust and believe that
things will go well and our forefathers
did that our four mothers understood
that it's what they taught to their kids
and i believe that we need to go back to
that if we want to see america flourish
as a free and just society
even economically even educationally
all of these things i think are our
fruit
on the tree with the roots going down
into faith and and virtue
and that's what i'm trying to get people
to think about hoping that
we the people of america will come up
with a solution and not wait for our
hope to fly in on air force one it ain't
coming
not not from any air force one but
particularly not from the guy on this
air force one
which uh which one of your sons did i
meet how how old is he
so that's james and james is 18 and uh
he actually took his last math final
today
and graduated high school wow very
exciting day
do i say congratulations to you i guess
so you're the dad you got yes
thanks thank you so tell jay as i said
congratulations but the reason
i bring him up is because i met you at
an event in florida a bunch of his
friends were around there
and you were saying oh dave you know you
you've affected these kids and and i
love hearing that because it's like oh
that means that there are young people
who are
thinking about freedom thinking about
all the things that i talk about
are you are you hopeful like when you
talk to your kids of those ages who are
going to be the ones that
get us out of this mess like are you
hopeful that they can do it
yeah i am hopeful that they can do it
it's it's always young people that have
the
that that their frontal well a they they
they they have all of this energy all of
this passion and they want to change the
world right
i mean you you talk about young people
and always talking about
they they want cultural change they want
a revolution and they want to be part of
something bigger than themselves
a lot of a lot of the uh the older folks
i'm 50 now
uh we we have gray hair which is a sign
of wisdom we've been around a while to
see
that all this history stuff is actually
important
and so uh when you're young you need a
vision
and and so i think that if we give the
vision
as older wiser people who understand
that ideas have consequences
that history can teach us uh about where
we're headed in the future
that if they get on board with with that
and they're inspired
if if uh if if they catch the vision
that's rooted in the right stuff i think
that
that not only i don't think that they
who are going to make the difference
i'm banking on the power of god
working in their hearts and through
their minds uh to make better decisions
than we've made in this generation
that's where my hope is
what have you done you and your wife i
guess to to make sure your kids are not
infected by so much of what's going on
out there with with critical race theory
identity politics just all the cultural
norms
because i get a ton of questions about
that from people that are
of our old age 45 and 50 that are like
what do i do about the kids
yeah well that's a great question and
and i don't um
i i don't have the i don't know that i
have a
one-size-fits-all fix for that but you
know we homeschooled our kids for many
years
and we didn't do that because we were
running away from something we felt we
could offer our kids a superior
educational path by teaching them the
values
uh and giving them the sources of
information
and history about and government and
literature and and
faith that they weren't going to get at
a regular school and then
some of the years were actually spent at
private schools as well
but but this stuff is that you're
talking about is per it's pervasive and
so
you know honestly i i i invite friends
my kids friends and my friends to sit
around a campfire like this
and and to say hey what do you think of
that flag you know what what do you what
is important to you what are your kids
uh what are your friends dealing with
right now
you know in relationships uh politically
uh
you know what are the taboo things that
you can and cannot say and then we
discuss those things
i i think not just swallowing the
narrative that's coming
in off of your social media feed um
but but researching things and and
that's even becoming increasingly
difficult right because stuff's getting
scrubbed off the internet and filtered
out to where
you know i i can't even say certain
words right now you and you and i might
get this video scrubbed
and so uh maybe you found a workaround
but it's
nice yeah last week we i had to edit for
the first time ever in all my years of
doing a show
we had david horowitz on he said
something that he believed
as a free person in a somewhat free
society but we knew that if we aired it
as is we were going to get
we could we were in risk of getting our
channel booted for the first time ever
i had to edit something or we put sound
bars over it
on youtube put it on my local channel
though
yeah well well that's great and and you
know what i hope dave is i hope
that we realize uh like like
oh you know that we're all sort of
kicking ourselves now going wait a
minute wait a minute why do we think of
creating our own social media channels
and news outlets
uh and keeping those free why don't we
think of that 40 years ago
you know but but the good news i think
now it's
we're waking up to it and and now these
things are beginning to be formed
and now we're beginning to be able to to
uh you know not not rely
on other people who disagree and want to
squash our message
to distribute and promote our message
that just doesn't make sense
but you know it was easy it was free and
uh
and so we just kind of went along with
it so i'm i'm
hopeful that we are at a very exciting
point in history
and that people are going to look back
on this generation and say
um there there were there were a few
people
they may have under uh you know
outfunded and outnumbered but they did
the right thing
and uh heaven was behind him and they
made the difference
that guy uh david beat goliath right am
i getting that story correct
he did he did but you know he was a
little guy
and david was a really big guy and i
think the lesson there is that uh
you know the only way that that story
ever makes sense
is when god is working through david
to defeat goliath and that's my hope is
that he'll also work through
us to uh to take down the nefarious
forces that would love to see freedom go
away
so for the people that have not seen the
campfire revival you are sitting at the
campfire right now you lit the fire for
us
hopefully you're not gonna self-immolate
or burn the flag while we're here
but you did this all just as we sat down
uh what are you doing over there at the
campfire revival on
on instagram and facebook is is that it
just just chat well i know what you're
doing
so i'm asking you i'm asking as the
audience not as myself i know what
you're doing
okay so so basically you know this all
started
you know after this whole last year and
then and through the election time and
the inauguration and people are talking
about the first hundred days of the
administration
and uh you know so many of us have been
sort of like waiting and hoping for
someone else to do
something and we're waiting for this to
happen and i thought to myself as i'm
sitting in my backyard
cooped up in uh california where you're
where you're
based basically and under house arrest
and lockdown uh at the time
wait a minute what's our plan what
what's what what kind of a
100-day plan could i be a part of
that's going to actually promote the
positive change rather than just
complaining about the things that i
don't like to see and i said you know
what
i don't know the best plan but i'm going
to start i'll plan and it's going to be
i'm going to sit in my backyard for 100
days in a row and build a campfire
and i'm going to invite other people to
join me as we pray
as we worship god and as we begin to
learn what made america the freest
strongest most prosperous nation in the
world
and and we found that on facebook live
we'd have 15 to 20
000 people every single night joining
and the comments were flying and people
made it a destination
every night because they found hope and
they found
something for them to to talk about with
their kids and we did that for 100 days
called it the american campfire revival
and it's all about that inside out
strategy that
bottom up strategy that our founders
understood
and that i think is going to be the
solution to getting us back to where we
want to go
yeah what else are you working on right
now are you going to be traveling again
and spreading the word and getting out
there i mean you're here in cali
they are we are opening up apparently at
some point
yeah that's that's right uh i am working
on quite a few things this american
campfire revival has been uh
just kind of a surprise joy for me to do
although all of my wardrobe smells like
smoke and my wife is
tired of it uh i'm roasting like a
marshmallow as we speak
uh my back is my backside is turning
golden brown you just
see it nice nice and um
we're gonna we're gonna continue this
and i'm about to start uh
another 40 days of the american campfire
revival
speaking about family covenants and then
community covenants church covenants and
civil government covenants
that kind of all weave together to to
form kind of this this kevlar fabric
that i believe will resist
the the the darts of tyranny and
totalitarianism
um in fact uh this is something i wanted
to show you yeah this is a pledge that i
kind of modeled
after the declaration of independence
called our pledge to renew the american
covenant
and it's what we can affirm together as
families and as individuals
to get back to these these values and
and we've signed it here
and i'm hoping people hang this in their
wall and talk about it as a family
and with their neighbors and then we
have some live events around the country
where we gather in fields and fields and
farms oh whoa
you didn't just no that's all right
we're good
we're good if you dropped the whole
covenant in the fire just then that that
would it
we're still good and uh and gather
around bonfires
and sing and pray and talk about what
really matters and uh
if we have one here in california i'll
make sure that i invite you i'd love to
have you come i'd love to come for a
second i thought newsom was about to try
to take you out i thought he you know
because he's got these
snipers out there people are in the
backyard having fun with an american
flag jeez
that's actually the first time that's
happened uh so uh
i think if you see any smoke coming from
behind me you let me know okay
yeah yeah i hope you have insurance for
this program uh wait so give me some of
the give me two or three of the uh
of the uh not edicts of the of the
principles that are on the
on the documentary yeah that's it um
let's see
uh boy here we go uh we promise to each
other as a family
to provide for one as long as we live
as commanded in scripture uh there's so
many others uh we commit to living
peacefully to obey the laws of the land
and and working to elect
uh godly trustworthy leaders who will
not abuse
their limited power as our public
servants and distort our constitution
so we talk about the the civic realm and
also the family realm
and also uh the uh the the community
realm
and and you know all of it really begins
with with self-government right
um i think this is important i think
people would find this interesting
uh when we talk about government we're
usually talking about them you know like
out there or up there we're talking
about
government and what they're doing but in
in our country our founders understood
that
that kind of government will be terrible
totalitarian government
unless we
lay the foundation of self-government
and if we govern ourselves
according to the the rules of right
right like it's not about left or right
it's about up or down and and if we go
up to the to heaven's rules of right
then we don't need the government with
the big stick
to beat us back into civility we've
already got that we got that
individually we got it in our families
we got it in our communities and
government can stay limited and small
and people have freedom
and so that's really the the essence the
most
powerful culture transforming force in
the world
is the self-governing person who loves
god and loves their neighbor
that's what our founders believed and
that's what i'm trying
to uh communicate to people which one do
you think is harder for your
old hollywood friends to swallow the the
belief part
or your feelings about government part
because they're probably not thrilled
with either
you mean government being limited yeah
well that you believe in small
government in the constitution that
america is good you know that
that sort of stuff is or the belief part
is that harder for them to swallow
oh boy um i don't know
you know it's all so so tied together um
but actually
i think that uh
it's interesting you said that small
government uh and that america is good
um you know the principles radicals is
bounded on is at are absolutely good the
framework
is genius it's beautiful but it depends
on personal self-government all of our
founders told
us that and the truth is i'm actually
for big government
but it's not what you think it's big
self-government
it's big family government and once we
take care of that
we we don't need a big police force
because we're doing the right thing
at the friend and family level i think a
lot of people are watching this going
what are you two fools still doing
in california i mean at this at this
point for you
is it is it just the weather i mean you
could be doing this in florida or calif
uh
florida or texas or tennessee
yeah yeah that's true and i certainly
understand why people are moving out of
here they're they're getting out of here
like rats jumping off of a ship
uh because we're sinking economically
and uh and
and politically however uh i'm all about
revival look at my shirt
american campfire revival revival right
so that means
like putting life back into things again
things that are flatlining and dying
reviving them
um i think that can happen anywhere i
think it can happen in my marriage
if my marriage is flatlining i think it
can happen uh in my family
my community i think it can happen in
our state and so i'm
hoping and praying that that ameri that
america and and starting with california
begins to see a renewal a revival and a
resurgence
of the kind of stuff that will cause
human flourishing
uh not human decay what do you think we
can do in this crazy
state i mean you know i'm hanging on by
a thread man
i i know i hear you i'm here well i'm
starting with a campfire
all right all right fair enough i'm all
right that's it i'm coming i'm coming to
the campfire
and i'm listening to you and i'm
listening to others
and uh and i believe that there are
people with more brilliant ideas than i
have
that uh are are gonna are gonna help
move us in the right direction
and uh and i continue to pray for them
do you find that people across the
country when you're traveling
regardless of whether you're red or blue
or any of that stuff that people
are pretty much the same uh oh oh what's
going on behind you now
[Music]
um the people are pretty much the same
what do you mean like uh
regardless of whether they're red or
blue if you can really get to them that
the stuff that you're talking about
is sort of the stuff that they really
believe some of them just don't know it
maybe
you know i think that people wanna
people wanna they wanna have a good job
they wanna be able to put food on their
table and provide for their family
um they they they wanna have a sense of
purpose
like their life counts for something and
uh i think people have been
sold different recipes on how to
how they're going to get that and so you
know politically
uh you know are are you going to have
somebody who's going to give you those
things
or give you the opportunity to work for
those things and invest in those things
uh
that that's that that's one aspect of it
but i think at the end of the day
if we're talking about values you know
i've got friends who
are on the other side of the aisle and
uh you know
they want the same things that i want i
i want an opportunity
to to provide for my family i want an
opportunity
to be able to speak the truth and not be
censored for it
i want an opportunity to to pursue
happiness
and and not be restricted and controlled
and thrown into a cage
because uh somebody disagrees with me
and
i i think there's there's a very
specific way to go about that
and uh that's what i'm trying to promote
yeah when you get those guys
on the other side of the aisle to come
to the campfire are they able to do it
because that's what a lot of my
let's say conservative friends are now
struggling with it's like yeah i'll have
that conversation with anybody
but they don't seem to want to have that
conversation with us
yeah yeah i do know what you're talking
about i
i i hope i'm not just uh you know
parroting something here i i think i
really do see
some groups of people um really going
after
facts and data and statistics
and i see other groups of people that
seem to not want to talk about those
things but really pour on
the the lighter fluid of emotion
and uh and sometimes not deal with the
issues i'm all about dealing with the
issues
and understanding what the facts are and
then let's work together
to solve problems um you know i
i've got a family too and i've got
neighbors too
and rather than the government taking my
money to
give to other people in an inefficient
way i would rather
keep my money and have a heart of
compassion that gets to know my neighbor
and help them out at the local level i
just think that's more efficient i think
that's better and it develops
relationships that cause communities to
flourish
where am i sending the fine people just
to kirkcameron.com
yeah if i send them to facebook i mean
you could say something and next thing
you know
long gone yeah so you know uh yeah just
send them to my website kirkcam.com
you've got all the info there
you can check out the american campfire
revival and uh and stay in touch
kirk i'm coming over for a campfire come
on
you're doing the s'mores you're doing
the s'mores i'm doing the s'mores
uh you know if you got some you got
something you want to grill on the fire
you just bring it bring it with you
you've seen some of the things i'm
grilling i'll i'll bring over the meat
and you've got like a crazy flame
thrower over there don't you i do this
guy gave it to me it's like a personal
flamethrower like
like every guy needs one especially if
you have a beard this is this is a tool
you need to have
in your in your in your toolbox it
throws out about a five
six foot flame and uh it's it's awesome
i will bring the meat you bring the
flame thrower keep the american flag
right there
we'll be able to start an evening we
will put it on instagram
or something let's do it all right
kirk cameron great seeing you man thanks
you too take care dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell